I'm Dimitri at rit's
we're using Gil pretty extensively over
there so I'm gonna talk about go and go
fridge is an overview of the talk is
first I want to talk about what if we
could comply with Gail to JavaScript
what would that look like theoretically
then I'll say that well go for J's can
kind of do that pretty well lots of
demos and examples and then I can answer
your questions that regarding
performance the code size the debugging
and all that okay let's talk about Gil
sure so if you can't tell from the
gopher on my laptop and my t-shirt I'm a
big fan of Gil I think it's pretty great
how many of you guys have used to go
just show of hands
great okay that's gonna make this a lot
easier so when I saw this tool it I knew
I had to put it in but this really
summarizes how I feel Gil is a
general-purpose language for building
simple reliable and fast software I feel
that is a pretty good description it's
fun to write and it's a good fit for
many use cases and I also feel that it's
gilling which to be writing library is
in why because whatever library you make
it's easily available if you're writing
Gale code you just import it you can go
get it and makes it easy to distribute
and it's also available on on multiple
platforms so there are these sort of
packages that's abstract out the
platform specific implementation details
so I keep reusing file path then it
doesn't matter if you're on Linux or
Windows oh sweet okay so I can use this
now but the idea is that your library
just uses file path and it works fine
and they're all these general interfaces
that you can use so if all you really
need to do is stream some data in you
can use io reader and there's a virtual
file system interface so those are great
now with that Gale can already target OS
X Linux windows arm it's sort of you can
release code for Android and one for and
iOS or it is supposed to be coming one
five there are others and
can be added so do you see like one
thing missing in this list okay let's
talk about Guildford yes
it's a compiler from Gil to JavaScript
its main purpose really is to give you
this opportunity to write Frenette codes
using guilt and it's still going to run
in all major browsers in theory there
could be more than one and there
actually is at least one more guilt to
JavaScript compiler so really I feel
like it's it's an implementation detail
but go for Jess it's a pretty cool
compiler so I'm gonna talk more about it
I think I'll just have to put this on
table here so here's the de repo for the
Gilford yes it has two thousand stars
one hundred Watchers it's basically it's
been a run for a while and it's made a
lot of progress it's written in the pure
go and it can actually compile itself so
there's a gorgeous playground that I'll
maybe show up later on
the main question you probably want to
see answer it is what is supported and
the answer is it's really nearly
everything including goroutines channels
and the Select same it there's a
compatibility table you can look at
right so here you can see all the
standard libraries and where it says yes
those are packages that have support and
the tests the actual Gil tests are
passing there's quite a lot of course
things like OS or maybe run time yeah
this works partially the compiler will
do some heavy lifting to make go
routines supported of course JavaScript
JavaScript does not have concurrency
built in but people this will allow you
to write normal go code that's idiomatic
and it will still work now I want to
show you how easy it is to get started
because a lot of the time I've seen this
project a while ago but I never actually
tried it until just one day decide ok
let me try it today and then realize I
should have done this sooner
so first I'll just make a quick HTML
page
so we'll have a script in here
okay so let's save that my desktop and
now if I look at this well it's just
index page there's nothing there
actually bad script it's not it doesn't
exist yet so let's make it well right in
and go though so go for Jess lets us do
println which is kind of this debugging
printing function it'll have that so
that whatever we print a line will go
into the the console so let's say hi
so I'm gonna go get it I already have it
so it's actually pretty fast and then
you just do gofer
it's basically just like the gal tool
but you can just do go for Jess build
script go and that generates the scrap
J's file so then when i refresh this
we've literally print it I just now so
I'm gonna make some more changes here
but before I do that having to recompile
this like you know it works but it's
kind of tedious I want to be able to
make changes to the code and then see
the results hold faster so what I'll do
is I'll use my own tool that basically
lets me write this so it's it's a little
command that I wrote go for Jess or HTTP
HTML I give it the HTML page and it
basically scans this file it finds all
these scrubs that have textile gil as
their type and it will kind of
internally compile the Gil to JavaScript
and then substitute of basically place
it in before serving it so when I do
this I can now refresh this well I do
have to go to this location now that
it's serving at and now I can see hi but
if I change the script to say like hello
then I can see that right away so let me
show you that goroutines work because
that's kind of the fun part so let's
make a channel
okay and I can do something like time
dot sleeve
and when I save that adds the time
Thanks yep okay so whenever fresh we'll
see that it says hello after a second
it'll say world okay so that's pretty
cool but we can only go so far with just
print aligning stuff so first let me
talk about like why why should I even go
on like why is it a good reason to try
to use Gil in the front end well there
are really many reasons so I mean no js'
it's a they had a some more idea they
wanted to be to be able to share the
common logic and Kalman kill between the
front and the back ends they use the
different language now for me I feel
like this is a really cool part but
there's a lot of familiar tools that you
can keep on if you're ready writing gale
codes you can keep on using like go FM
Tegel imports go doc is a big one you
can do build test so you can write your
tests the same way that you would write
for go codes you can actually do
benchmarks and compare like is this
implementation faster than the other
familiar types this is really cool you
can actually have a UN 16 that will
behave that way it's no need for an
equality table compilation errors that
means if you're refactoring and usually
just like with gel codes when it
compiles it will typically do what you
want you can do the same concurrency
goroutines blocking receiving so you
don't have to do the callback so you can
actually block do something that takes
time and then continue executing so
here's another cool reason there's a lot
of really cool Gil packages that can be
very easily compiled to JavaScript and
perform what they're doing so here's a
example of go parser and go printer
these internal bill packages and here's
a function written gal that parts and
inputs and I'm basically prints it out
and very quickly I can have that running
in a browser so this is that codes
running inside of my browser I think
I'll make this not full screen so you
can see it
I'll just start typing and you basically
go source file and as I'm typing it I
see that with every keystroke on the
right
it's parsing it and compiling so it's
kind of cool you can see how the parser
handles incomplete inputs and you can
see that if I type like for this whole
kind of format that's so now it's a
correct program and one way I can know
that this was a compiled with not 1.4
but the previous versions because this
is not supported ok so you can sort of
see that it this works now that was a
somewhat simple package you can actually
do a lot more so if you're familiar
would be Black Friday it's a markdown
parser and render blue Monday is another
Gil package that is for sanitizing HTML
then let's add syntax highlight on top
and a few more to basically create this
so close that but basically right now we
have a live markdown editor inside the
browser this is not talking to any
back-end service to do its job so I'll
clear that so one thing that it does is
if I I can format my markdown on the
left-hand side so that it it's nice so
that table becomes formatted that's one
feature I can write some Gil codes
so there's that I can still sort of
format that again this also supports
deaf files
so it's doing all that highlighting
basically in the front end because that
functionality or already exists in the
go packages that I've mentioned here so
on next slide here's what it really took
me to make that HTML page work really is
it's effectively one line its output set
its inner HTML to the result of the
github flavored markdown render okay so
if you had told me maybe two years ago
that here's like a working compiler from
guilty JavaScript it's absolutely
perfect but does everything go ahead use
it I would be like well I don't really
know how to use it like it's it's kind
of an odd thing to have so because the
browser it's this like it's a strange
execution environment so you have your
browser there's some JavaScript you can
write but what can you do and what can
you do about it and again to come back
to my previous point to do interesting
things you need to be able to do
something except just print a line to
the console so the key realization is
that the browser really is a collection
when you're on a web page it's a
collection of API so that are available
to you the biggest one being a Dom but
there's a lot more that are there
there's the xhr if you want to make
those kind of requests there's web
socket API there's webparts CC that's
pretty new there's WebGL geolocation all
these api's are available to you and
typically it's always been you have your
Java code JavaScript killed that is
accessing beasts api's and doing
whatever it is that your application
wants to do in the front-end so of
course to be able to do that go for Jess
it has a way of you for you to look to
access those API so for example if you
want to achieve the effect of document
this will be JavaScript codes document
writes hello worlds this is how go for
Jess allows you to do that so if you
look at this Gil doc page it's an
internal package that you imports sculpt
get up calm go for days go for jsj yes
and it effectively has a very useful
object
variable okay it has a VAR global this
is what you'll most likely be using and
it's basically the global objects
usually window for browsers and it has
the object interface so this lets you
get set
delete things etc etc so this is how you
would be able to to achieve bats so you
get documents you call write with hello
world you can still you can also kind of
do this other thing where you provide
you have an existing Gale function and
you can basically expose it to the rest
of your JavaScript codes by doing set
and then now you're setting in the
JavaScript world effectively some
function to be whatever you've written
here it's using whenever you go between
like the gilt types and the JavaScript
types it uses this type conversion table
so here are the gil types over here you
have the javascript types and you can
effectively make those conversions
there's somewhat expensive so of course
you should try to avoid doing it if you
can but you know you have to so what
ends up being is that now you have
potentially Gil killed in the side that
you could write and compile it to
JavaScript and you can access the same
API so you would with JavaScript so you
can start doing more things but what you
know you don't want to have to do that
kind of code that I've shown you before
because this is actually this is like
writing this and JavaScript is a lot
easier on the other hand what is
possible is to write these wrappers that
basically present go very nice idiot
potentially idiomatic Gil interfaces on
top of the API that the browser has so
we'll start off with the Dom API there
is a package that basically does that
it's gonna be a huge one as you can
imagine it's this is the entire Dom but
this is a Gil package that you can
import and start using it if your code
is running inside the browser and you
can look at how to use its API it's it's
definitely well-documented and fairly
straightforward to use and it works like
this is test it codes there's a package
for
xhr this one is a lot simpler but if you
want to do an xhr request this is what
you have to do it's basically a
low-level wrapper that mimics the
JavaScript API and here's like a helper
function to make it a little bit easier
there's a WebGL API so you can
potentially do something with the
graphics etc etc so you can look for
more over here but with that you
basically have the ability now for your
for your guild code to access the nicer
Gil packages that expose that
functionality that you're interested in
there are also bindings for JavaScript
libraries I'm not going to talk much
about this because I haven't actually
used much of them I know they exist like
the go angularjs it's used and go for
J's playground you can take a look I I
don't know much more about it and if in
case you're a library using doesn't
actually implement something you can
always go to kind of the JavaScript
directly so here's an example that Dom
packaged it basically implements
everything except the history so like I
couldn't do that that's not implemented
so I just basically that it's directly
with the J's global object instead so
you're still able to do that just want
to talk more a little bit a little bit
more about the Gopher Jess project so
it's developed by one guy effectively
Richard and he has some incredible
response times for Asia so by now it is
a pretty complete project so but if
somebody reports like a bug or an issue
in the compiler it's pretty rare but
when it happens he fixes them pretty
quickly so there was an issue where it
took him 14 hours to fix like a serious
compiler bag oh yeah I think that's
pretty impressive so just to give you an
idea of the state of this project like a
year and a half ago maybe less than that
just just over a year ago this was still
the road map back then in 2013 so like
he still wanted to implement all these
things the reflection was not complete
there was no goroutine supports you
couldn't even go to all these things are
now done just to give you
the status and the progress that it's
made so it's still an evolving project
but it's definitely made a lot of
progress okay I'm gonna change the topic
a little bit and give you a slightly
different demo so here's an OpenGL app
that I made some time ago as you can see
it's a very simple it's just like a
little toy project just one file just
main that go let me run it for you
so as expected it's just a desktop
application that starts up and it
renders this terrain now what would it
take for me to be able to run this in a
browser and this was something that I've
wanted to do a long time ago and it
turns out in this case not a whole lot
so what I'm doing here is I'm using two
packages that are somewhat different
there's the Gil GL and there is Gil gfw
so what go GL is it's basically a an
OpenGL like interface that actually has
two backhands there is a there is a
browser back-end which is basically Bob
GL and there's a desktop one which uses
opengl 2.1 and the same idea for gil gfw
this is typically a library that lets
you create a window and get input from
it and stuff like that so that not also
has a back-end for the browser so if I
do go for just serve HTML and there's a
negative index page
this is now that exact same Gill file
that you saw previously running in my
desktop it's now running in the browser
okay here's another one
so this is another small demo it uses a
package gilt colada this is a colada 3d
file format loader it is a pure gil
package so when I saw it I thought well
let's see what happens
does it work and turns out that it does
ok it's gonna be the old one here's a
new one so now that's floating a 3d
model in the browser the reason that it
works is going back to my mentioning of
sort of general interfaces is it has it
has two functions they'll let you load
the document one of them is you're
giving it a file name it's obviously
that's not gonna work in a browser the
other one is you're giving it a reader
and I'm actually able to provide a
reader by using the xhr request that
gets it from filesystem in the backend
but this lets let's it work in the
front-end and so I'm actually like these
are small sort of demos that are parts
of a bigger project that I was working
on that is also something that I can run
in the browser now okay
so this is basically putting together
the terrain and the model and here we
have that model little track and it's
not a finished game yet but yeah you can
kind of move around and stuff but to
really I the point that this is pretty
cool I'm just gonna show you I have a
branch here
okay so it has one commit on top of the
previous branch and it's basically a
place where I started working on the
physics so as you can see it's just one
commit and all it is
I'm just modifying you know velocity the
position there is nothing specific to
the browser there's nothing specific to
the the desktop version of it is just
it's just the logic of the program and
if I if I serve that again
so now we have physics okay it's it's a
beginning I'm getting there but
nevertheless it was not easy for me to
make it work in the browser I didn't
have to do anything special for it all
right so here are some other demos of
people trying out Guildford yes for some
things here's like this sort of like the
matrix effect that's running in the
browser this is also using Guildford yes
to make it work somebody wrote a very
simple pong game so that's what it looks
like and you can run it this works in
the browser too you can look at the
source code and see that it is indeed
okay I'm not good at it you can see that
it's written and go so that's the source
very simple things but it's basically
using the canvas and drawing those
rectangles and you're able to have that
running in the browser - oh and one more
thing is Gil tools don't work this is a
project that I've worked on it's
basically a website that shows you all
the shows you the source of an eagle
package this also uses gopher jazz for
all of its front-end stuff like the idea
was that I wanted to try it out I mean
previously I was showing you graphics
related stuff but I want to see what it
would take to achieve something if it's
you know if I need to access the Dom or
do something like that so this thing on
the right hand side here that is
implemented in Gil works fine and you
can also navigate to different symbols
again using go
okay it's talking about compile errors
just to give you a process of a better
idea as to what it actually feels like
when you're developing using Gil for the
front-end so if you do something silly
like this you're giving an int and it's
expecting a slice of bytes you're gonna
get a very obvious error cannot convert
int on type in constant to slice of
fight/flight slice if you're gonna try
to convert or assign this to an i/o
reader it doesn't implement IO reader so
you're gonna say you cannot you cannot
do that these are just like very similar
errors to what you'd expect from a from
Gil what does debugging look like say
hello to println I mean you do get panic
stack traces but very often you'll just
print things and you're gonna see them
but really like static type checking and
these compilers so you get in the front
in the first place they really catch a
lot of things you would have to debug
otherwise but just to give you a better
idea here's a like I've purposely
inserted this panic in the middle of
some very deeply nested code and when
that happens you get an uncaught error
demonstrating the go panic and then if
you look at it you get a very nice stock
trace so you can see that it went inside
of main process markdown second pass etc
until went to in line and if you look at
the actual generated source codes this
is the go for a jazz output effectively
it's not minified by the way here that's
what it looks like so this looks very
similar to the original gear code that
had the panic which makes it very easy
for you to go back in and debug it the
performance okay well it's not gonna be
faster than handwritten JavaScript but
at the same time it's not a whole lot
slower and as I found
it's definitely acceptable for most
general use cases and very often I did
try to push a one time a heads I think
like 50,000 dev elements at the same
time something like that it was
basically Dom manipulation that was
really hurting the performance at that
time so you can also do things like
guilt testbench
and profile your JavaScript codes that
you end up getting and see like how
performant it is if you really need to
and again this is definitely a viable
thing to achieve performance if
something is slow and it's in a tight
loop you can actually just use
JavaScript for that do whatever it is
you want to do and then use gopher jazz
for all the other things there is asm.js
support plans there's an issue body but
it's not yet done and who knows what
will happen in 50 years from now or 35
so do you mean the this benchmark Gil
pest bench yeah right so there's a mode
that uses nodejs and it will run the
JavaScript but it's gonna use nodejs
it's not gonna mean the browser yeah
yeah it's it's yeah it gives you
something there are some performance
steps like if you care about performance
you might want to do a few small tweaks
but again don't really worry about these
until until you really get to a point
where you have to worry about it so but
some basic things will be like use the
EM flag so that's minify and definitely
apply gzip compression a little shell by
on the next slide and there have been
huge improvements made so if you
remember that little pop-up box that
happens when I was in OC 5 when I was
here so this part it took like two and a
half seconds to load I kind of use it as
a benchmark so two point two seconds and
this is very kind of slow unoptimized
gale codes that I purposely left that
way just to see what happens so it takes
two and half seconds on the other hand
the like the native version of it I
think it tastes maybe 200 milliseconds
or 100 and see what happens yeah I took
eighty six milliseconds so it looks like
it's about
you know an order of magnitude like ten
times slower so now when I started off
this was actually taking 30 seconds in a
browser and I made an issue but it's
it's like okay it's taking 30 seconds
that's kind of along can you take a look
at it and Richard Ed's and I ended up
making quite a few improvements and
basically at the end here's like a table
of comparison it went from 30 seconds
originally to three seconds without
really any changes just optimizations
and it tooks
it takes 13 seconds on my iPad so you
weld the same page so I guess my Mac
looks a little faster but it's
interesting you can compare performance
of like your mobile device with your or
your desktop size of the generated code
so I have a table here you can take a
look but basically when you have a very
simple whole world application it will
be it will have a fixed sized overhead
because it has to do all these sort of
bootstrapping work to make your work for
all the go codes but then if you adds
more kill to that you know you're gonna
add more just same type of code it will
not get much larger so here's like a
simple Gil file that doesn't use any
imports and ends up being twelve
kilobytes in the end when it's using
just FMC and a little bit of codes it's
89 but then you add more killed it's
still 89 but then the biggest I've seen
it gets like if I import every single
package I can think of it ends up being
and just like eleven thousand lines of
gilt codes all at once it's in that 200
300 kilobyte range so it's big but it's
it's the worst in a browser some
limitations the biggest one right now is
even though concurrency is supported you
do have to mark some of the blocking
cows as basically like you have to add
this comment go for Jess blocking to let
it know that this is a blocking color
this only happens when you're basically
passing in an interface to a function
and basically the when it's compiling it
looks through the cook the go killed
that you've written and it tries to
figure out which of the cost could be
blocking but when it's an
interface it cannot know at compile-time
if you'll be blocking or not so you have
to do this thing and it could be a
problem if you have something in the
standard library that you cannot modify
but yeah there is ongoing work to make
that better
that is really the biggest issue right
now yep this is like maybe three more
two more yeah so yeah this basically
prevents you from implementing blocking
i/o reader and Netcom which is kind of a
shame because if you could then you you
would be able to like basically
implement NAT con using a WebSockets and
then drop that in and then use JSON RPC
package and you could basically
implement the HTTP client by giving it a
custom transport that wraps around xhr
all these cool things that are not yet
quite doable but maybe soon yeah of
course if you're going to distribute an
app that uses this there's gonna be more
steps you have to now compile this Gil
to JavaScript but maybe you can use go
generate with that if you're loading an
HTML page it's best to have just one of
these go for JSON pulped scripts in
there because be up to that's pad you're
gonna have to overhead up to bill
runtimes effectively it's still young
and evolving but as you can see it's
pretty uh you know it's pretty advanced
by now so there's maybe less people
familiar with gilt and JavaScript okay
but some advantages are you basically
get to use going I think that's that is
the single hand biggest advantage so you
feel you want to ride go codes and run
in a browser then go for justice for you
but I mean really the takeaway message
that I want to give you from this talk
is that really like which language using
the front end whether it's JavaScript or
potentially go it's really a choice you
have to make you should sort of
investigate the trade-offs and you know
see what you want to do what do you
enjoy writing more etc and think more
about like if somebody makes a poor
request for this repo and it's it's in
JavaScript and you know what is it gonna
look like versus what if it's in Gil and
you know what if I have to deal with
this two years from now so really it's
you know completely up to you but I'm
definitely having a lot of fun writing
kill kill in the front end and you know
I see that it's still there's still more
things you can do to make it better but
it's it's a pretty cool thing to be
doing so you can you know something to
try at home is play with the gopher just
playground and maybe think of a Gil
package you like and see if it can be
compiled here's a community pay more
community stuff you can find it's
basically in the github repo thank you
very much yes right so so basically how
does it handle the concurrency and all
the blocking code because javascript is
not supposed to block write the way does
it is and I'm not an expert on its
internals but what I do know is it
basically it analyzes all your go killed
that can be blocking and you know it
effectively uses closures to kind of
save states if you get to a blocking
point it saves the state and it kind of
unwinds the stack and returns and then
when it resumes like it will basically
see if there's another girl team that
could be running instead etc etc so it
really does have to kind of save the
state unwind a sock and then resume
either another girl routine or just
return to the browser
right so web workers were definitely
considered when we when Richard and we
were discussing like what are some
possible ways to implement concurrency
it's you cannot really like go web
workers are kind of more heavyweight
than go routines so you cannot do a
one-to-one mapping but there may be some
other things you can do but it but it
was it was something I was discussed and
they're not used at this time right well
all I can say is that they're not using
web workers right now but it was
definitely considered and it could be
revisit in the future but you should
take a look to that issue where it was
discussed and and see what you can find
is that a question so if you have a Gil
compilation like you know in there and
your Gil codes go for a guess what I
should give you an error sable to look
like something that I've shown here well
that's not that's a panic but
oh yeah so okay I yeah I kind of skipped
over this thing so what happens the two
little bit I was using to make my life
easier when there's a guilt compilation
error it basically just makes this like
mock javascript file that just does like
you know console dot error and it just
dumps all these error messages for me so
I can see them in a browser yeah so this
like basically in this case there was no
proper JavaScript generated it's just
yeah yeah these are compile time errors
that go fridge as generated but they do
end up in the browser for yeah for
visibility relevant but this is not a
not a runtime area of JavaScript
conditional compilation flags right yeah
so go Fred jazz definitely supports that
and respects that and that's how I was
able to basically have these like an
OpenGL like package that had different
backends so when when you're compiling
it on your desktop it's using like OS X
Bill tags and if you're running in the
browser it's theirs so uses the je s as
its architecture so you can use that as
the as the yeah it's the Bill tag filter
I think somebody was working either on
bindings for it or playing around with
it like I I think I've seen that
recently but I haven't I don't have more
to say on that but it's yeah it's
definitely a cool thing to try